عامر هل هناك تفاصيل جديده بشان هذه
الانفجارات التي دوت شرقي العاصمه
العراقيه
الليى نعم ليلى الى الان لا يوجد تفاصيل
يعني مفصله بخصوص ما جرى باستثناء ما
تحدثنا عنه ونوجز ما جرى حتى الان اذا هي
طائره مسيره من المفترض وم المتوقع كما
تقول المصادر الامنيه بانها مسيره امريكيه
استهدفت سياره رباعيه الدفع كان يستقلها
ثلاثه اشخاص من المفروض انهم قاده في
الحشد الشعبي او في المقاومه الاسلاميه في
العراق نحاول التاكد تحديدا من هذه
الجزئيه
بالتفصيل قتل ثلاثه في هذا الهجوم على
راسهم واصبح الان من شبه المؤكد ان ابو
بكر ابو باكر الساعدي وهو قيادي كبير يوصف
بانه ربما ثاني ارفع شخصيه يتم اغتيالها
في العراق بعد ابو مهدي المهندس
هذا القيادي تم اغتياله في السياره مع
اثنين من مرافقيه وهو المسؤول على
المنظومه الجويه كما فهمنا حتى الان
السياره استهدفت في منطقه في شرق بغداد
تحديدا في حي المشتل اشتعلت النيران الان
المنطقه تطوقها قوات الامن العراقيه بسياج
امني مشدد وتمنع اي احد من الاقتراب لكن
في محيط هذا الطوق الامني علمنا قبل قليل
بان هناك مظاهرات شعبيه عفويه بدات ت
يعني تتكون وتحتشد ال الناس المواطنون
بداوا بالاحتشاد في المكان يرددون هتافات
تندد بالولايات المتحده وتطالب المقاومه
العراقيه باستهدافها وتحرض عليها وتقول
بانه لا يمكن السماح للقوات الامريكيه
بالبقاء في العراق وب بعد هذا التجاوز هذا
طبعا ايضا ياتي في نفس الحديث وفي نفس
البيانات التي تصدر عن الحكومه العراقيه
وعن مختلف الاحزاب السياسيه العراقيه
والنخب العراقيه وحتى البرلمان العراقي في
كل مناسبه يتم استهداف فيها منظومه الحشد
الشعبي خصوصا ان هذه المنظومه هي جزء لا
يتجزا كما يقولون من القوات المسلحه
العراقيه وتتبع القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه واستهدافها هو استهداف للعراق
ولسيادتك السكوت على هذا الاستهداف لان
العراق ليس كما وانا هنا انقل عن رئاسه
الوزراء التي يعني ذكرت في اكثر من مناسبه
اضافه الى وزاره الخارجيه ونتوقع طبعا
اقول هذا الكلام لان نتوقع ان نصدر بيانات
مشابهه الحكومه قالت بانها لا تريد للعراق
ان يصبح ساحه للتبادل ولتصفح الحسابات
ولاق
حاامد مات الاقليميه في المنطقه وترفض ما
تقوم به الولايات المتحده ومطالبه كما
ذكرت لك في معظم المرات السابقه نذكر طبعا
بان هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يتم فيها
اغتيال شخصيات منذ بدء الح حرب على غزه في
الرابع من يناير الماضي استهدفت القوات
الامريكيه ابو تقوى وهو احد القياديين في
حركه النجباء استهدف هنا في قلب العاصمه
بغداد هو ومرافقه ايضا كان في سياره
واثناء دخول مقر القياده التابع له استهدف
هنا في العاصمه بغداد لكن كما ذكرنا هذا
الاستهداف له يعني ابعاد اخرى خصوصا انه
كما فهمنا هو مقرب من حزب الله العراقي
نعلم ويعلم الجميع انه امريكي حزب الله
العراقي هو المتهم بالعمليه التي ادت الى
مقتل ثلاثه من الجنود الامريكيين في
القاعده البرج 21 التي هي من المفترض في
الاردن كما قالت الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي حزب الله العراقي هو المستهدف
الاول كما كان يفترض وكما كان الحديث منذ
بدايه الحديث عن الرد الامريكي الاستهداف
والرد الامريكي الاول كان عندما استهدفت
القوات الامريكيه الاسبوع الماضي القواعد
قواعد تابعه للح الحشد الشعبي ادت الى
مقتل 16 من الحشد وتحديدا في مدينتي
القائم والعكاز وهما في اقصى غرب العراق
في محافظه الانبار عند الحدود مع سوريا تم
تدمير مواقع مخازن للاسلحه ومواقع ومقرات
للحشد الشعبي وكما ذكرنا صدرت العديد من
البيانات التي تستنكر ما جرى على اعتبار
انه انتهاك صارخ كما قالت الحكومه وكما
قالت الخارجيه وما كما قال البرلمان ايضا
لسياده العراق وطالبت الولايات المتحده
بعدم اقحام العراق في الازمات وعدم جعله
ساحه لتصفيه الحسابات اذا الان السؤال
الكبير باعتقادي ليلى هو ما الذي سيحدث
بعد الان الولايات المتحده عندما نفذت هذه
الضربات كان هدفها المعلن هو ايقاف
الاستهداف للقواعد العسكريه الامريكيه
سواء في العراق او في سوريا لكن فصائل
المقاومه وهنا انوه واذكر بان حزب الله
الع العراقي المتهم كما قلنا بقتل الجنود
الامريكيين اعلن في بيان رسمي له بانه علق
العمليات منعا للاحراج على الحكومه منعا
لاحراج الحكومه العراقيه لكن فصائل اخرى
على راسها النجباء وغيرها قالت باننا
نتفهم هذا القرار لكننا سنواصل استهداف
القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه في المرحله
القادمه حتى تتوقف الحرب على غزه وحتى
تنسحب القوات الامريكيه من العراق وبعد
الاستهداف الذي يعني ضرب القائم والعكاز
استمرت الاستهدافات وين بوتيره اقل حيث
استهدفت قاعده حرير قرب مطار اربيل
واستهدفت ايضا قاعده عين الاسد في الانبار
واستهدفت عده قواعد تابعه للولايات
المتحده في داخل الاراضي السوريه على يد
المقاومه العراقيه